[Musica]
buonasera buonasera
lei e maura e lui a diego noi siamo
improvvisatori teatrali
noi raccontiamo storie le costruiamo e
le portiamo in scena a teatro su un
palco con un pubblico con delle luci
magari della musica c'è tutto l'unica
cosa che non abbiamo è un copione non ce
l'abbiamo non abbiamo neanche un
canovaccio niente neanche due appunti
scritti le nostre storie nascono al
momento all'improvviso sulla base di
quello che abbiamo per le mani sulla
base di stimoli che chiamiamo input di
essere input esterni esterni come una
parola del pubblico un gesto un suono
una posizione delle braccia
oppure delle input interne si possono
essere anche delle mozioni degli stati
d'animo dei pensieri che
l'improvvisatore si porta da casa e che
condizionano la storia la cambiano e
cambiano anche il suo personaggio questi
suggerimenti questi stimoli sono una
scintilla che mette in moto le storie
che noi andiamo a raccontare ecco di
fatto noi non sappiamo come iniziamo
non sappiamo come finiamo e soprattutto
come possiamo sapere cosa c'è in mezzo e
poiché queste storie vengono raccontate
a quattro mani a sei mani ha rotto maria
multipli di due di mani e sono tanti gli
attori in scena di solito e quindi
bisogna anche accettare e accogliere le
idee degli altri attori le proposte e
questo è possibile soltanto se c'è
l'ascolto l'ascolto che non è soltanto
il possesso di due trombe di eustachio
ma è la disponibilità a farsi cambiare
ecco cambiare ma parliamo anche di
qualcosa di più che fa paura spiazzare e
cos'è allora io vi chiedo se siete
d'accordo di fare un gioco con noi ci
siete anche noi o che grazie perfetto
sentito un sì perfetto ok vi chiedo in
questo momento pensa te tutti quanti una
parola una parola un oggetto che ce
l'avete si perfetto
questo oggetto questa parola non vi
chiederemo di usarla di urlarla magari
chi vuole quando vedrà uno degli attori
alzare la mano in questa prossima
improvvisazione facciamo una prova ecco
chiedo a te in prima fila si
il titolo di questa improvvisazione sarà
martello martello il martello si
scusi signora carla arrivata ben
questa volta non è per il mio cavallo no
si è rotto il tacco
sarà la festa alla festa di
alla festa di cuore
la festa dove tutti quanti andiamo solo
noi ex trapiantati di cuore
sì esatto la conosco finanziava la
timber tra l'altro è forse so ho la
soluzione le conviene portare con sé un
un tasso un tasso eccolo qui è il 10 per
cento iva esclusa grazie si considera
tranquillo a potrà accedere evitare
anche le evasioni fiscali io la
ringrazio grazie a questo tasso adesso
alla festa finalmente potrò puo essere
una come tanti potrò essere una
potrei essere una foglia potrà fluttuare
e andare di uomo in un uomo sì io non lo
so cosa vuole fare lei vuole mettere
radici in quella situazione e allargarsi
a ramificare e conquistare l'uomo della
sua vita ma
la sedia si è quello che io voglio poi
un posto mi voglio sedere nella società
mi voglio sposare
non voglio più stare in piedi come una
single perché capite le single stanno in
piedi o meglio una sedia voglio basta
allora le chiedo di quando avrà di
fronte l'uomo della sua vita sì gli dica
giraffa sì perché lei con tutto questo
tempo ha fatto il collo a muro
oh sì
[Applauso]
grazie grazie per
i vostri suggerimenti che sono stati
spiazzanti ma l'improvvisatore deve
cavalcare il cambiamento lo deve
accettare e farsi e doversi adattare in
corsa a farsi cambiare e prenderlo come
un opportunità e questo erano degli
stimoli esterni ma abbiamo detto anche
degli stimoli interni è possibile che
l'attore personaggio avverta delle
emozioni e decidere con queste di
cambiare si stimola interno quindi
l'emozione che decide il corso della
storia
facciamo un esempio faccio chiamo ancora
una volta insieme vorremmo tre mozioni
partiamo dalla prima
la gioia la felicità
un'altra diversa molto diversa
la triste la tristezza è un'altra la
rabbia rabbia allora questo enorme
spazio scenico a nostra disposizione
noi lo divideremo in tre sezioni ideali
quindi qui c'è la gioia in mezzo c'è la
tristezza e qui c'è la rabbia è che qui
prova gioia chi è qui prova tristezza e
chi di noi sarà qui trova la rabbia ma
ci serve ancora un input di vi chiedo
una parola di quelle che avete pensato
non avete detto
il bacio bacio perfetto bacio spazi
genio che cosa vuoi
eugenio eh lo so lo so lo so ho
sbagliato sbagliato non sapevo che
dovevo starci più attento nei partita
lingue per un fratello 8 perdonami
io ti voglio dare un'altra opportunità
perché vedi
o un altro occhio
e se poi te li faccio fuori entrambi
non sarei qui alle narici
non posso coprire tutti i tuoi orifizi
non erano questi i nostri accordi
eugenio eugenio
prego
facciamo
allora sei guarda guarda fai tu fai tu
qui
my lai
casa
perché è solo saliva il fondo ma è un
inizio
pelazza del tuo corpo ne entra nel mio
corpo più scarna nota abbiamo detto che
era a quel livello non ci arriviamo
ancora mi sento impreparato e uccelli
ero già quando noi ci siamo sposati si
tu hai giurato davanti a tutto il mondo
davanti al nostro signore capitare
questi giorni così tristi tony scott e
chiaramente tu voglia di qua e mi dai un
bacio come lo so se darà pace
vuol dire il signore lo chiede al
signore
che mi hai capito no voglio stare qua
d'accordo allora te puoi passo spedito
al bacio però basta dei smettere
dispiace se ci spostiamo
ed hanno la stoffa c'è
beh questo era un altro esempio di come
il cambiamento sia parte integrante
dell'improvvisazione l'improvvisazione
teatrale le storie sono pregni è basata
interamente su sul cambiamento
allora a questo punto io
mi viene da chiedere a un improvvisatore
se dovessi chiedere ma ora qual è il
momento giusto per cambiare
adesso
[Applauso]